freunde herzlich zu einer neuen folge
einen tag persönlicher koch die camps
mittlerweile ich bin wie immer zu spät
also ich kaufe dir und ich fange an mit
milchreis ich habe ja einen topf aus wut
und indem wir jetzt einfach alle zutaten
auf einmal
wir brauchen zb 150 gramm zucker zur
firma an zucker rein dann brauchen wir
unsere milch kreis und was martina
schoder so funktioniert auch aber wir
machen das ganz klassisch christ
milchreis davon nehmen wir von 125 gramm
und 3 dann brauchen wir so eine bio
zitrone und nehmen davon an be oder wie
charlie ist ein geben und nehmen davon
die hälfte der schale
wichtig ist dass sie vor den topf fließt
könnte sie auch schon nehmen und in den
verbreitungsrecht schon komplett wählt
dann bis 600 liter milch oder sagen wir
mal 650 kommt auch dazu dann brauchen
wir eine halbe vanilleschote verlieren
wir treffen sie nun aus wo sieht das
ganze aus so dann gehen wir die
vanilleschote und das mach einfach auch
zum job dazu
und jetzt gehen wir das ganze auf den
markt und kostet uns einfach auch dabei
das ganze immer mal umrühren dann
erstmal warten bis es auf klappt so
leute ihr seht ihr mit reise vom kochen
das heißt wir drehen jetzt hier jetzt
schon wieder runter neben den deckel
drauf und ab jetzt dauert das ganze noch
ca 30 minuten die drüben habe ich noch
ein top aufgesetzt und in den gebe ich
jetzt hier spritze
so freuen nachdem das so schnell ging
werde ich mir zumindest noch die mühe
machen und die bei deinen leisten kaffee
machen einen cappuccino und ein eis
latte macchiato ich muss es nur sehr gut
teil weil ich fahre ja zu ihm wir wohnen
nicht unendlich weit voneinander weg
aber das darf nicht das darf nicht kalt
werden mit sachlichkeit werden deshalb
ist es wirklich so etwa das ganze
übrigens in dem ich 21 gramm frischen
kaffee auf malle kann man das noch ein
bisschen ausgleichen indem man
so dran schlägt dann drückt man es noch
mal an mit dem tempo dann haben wir
unser café sie vorbereitet man kann den
rand da noch ein bisschen saubermachen
hängt es 1 25 sekunden sollte in best
idea café extra aktionen dauern
träger ist verrückt aber das sind alles
schritte mit dem man garantieren kann
dass die qualität sehr gut fangen an mit
dem ice blood markt dafür habe ich
parallel soße und karamell sirup erstmal
hier so auf starbucks teil mache ich
hier erst mal das glas voll dran kommt
dazu ein kleiner shop wirklich nur weil
ich mag es nicht so süß von karamell
tiere haben jede menge frisches frisch
ist als jede menge eis wird und dann
kommt am ende unser espresso schott und
fertig ist ein sehr starbucks tauglicher
ist carol motto so dann haben wir hier
noch unsere zweite nespresso wollen die
will ich auch sehr sehr schlecht deckel
drauf fertig so und jetzt können wir
auch hier machen natürlich letzten
fördern wir das ganze in ein
professionelles catering das für das aus
plastik besteht von beginn ist hier rein
und hoffen lassen nichts weg schmeckt so
da sind sich auch mit liebe und du hast
jetzt zum frühstück eine schöne
milchreis gewünscht ich dachte ich kann
mich ja nicht nur mit einem milchreis
hier besuchen kommt deshalb lassen wir
erst mal die wahl also ein fischer
cappuccino falls du das gerne machen
weil sich ein bisschen so basic bridge
bist im eiskeller macchiato dabei auch
endlich trinks überhaupt kaffee ja ich
bin echt nicht mehr kann ich trinke
mache
und probiere gerne michael ich geb dir
dann aber auch von dem ich hoffe der
dort wo ist denn ich war ja ich fühle
mich vom herd ins auto und punkt hier
drüber ich hier mal direkt was auch ich
bin sehr kritisch fest ist dann ja und
dann gehören dazu natürlich noch heißt
ihr spielhaus mit hier ist ein wildtier
schon das ist heute so auf meinen canal
du nimmst ein fachmann lässt aber durch
die nicht zu viel raus also bewertet man
nicht rütteln lassen auch die wirkung
dann geht die kamera aus du kannst gerne
gut essen
viele sehen uns wenn du auf gespräch das
zu bewerten
also das ist dir schmecken ich bin sehr
gespannt wie bringe ich die gleichen ak
wir sehen uns wenn auch gegessen ist zur
bewertung von khedira
der teller als lehrer geburten als
lassen ist auch schon heute lernt dass
man nur an der keinen kaffee mag ich bin
gespannt wie deine bewertung ausfällt
also erstmal finde ich sehr stark dass
das essen am tag muss ich ehrlich sagen
dass ich mag es nicht heiß und es war
für mich die perfekte temperatur ich
verbrenne unfassbar schnell die
zionisten war das sehr schön ein
bisschen laufen und grundsätzlich war
das ein spaß ich esse milchpreise
unfassbar gerne und der hier war aber
gut weil er nicht zu süß und viele
machen den fehler dass sie halt sagen
nur süßes essen und ich glaube ich jetzt
so richtig viel raffinierten zucker rein
und ich weiß nicht was das schwarze war
das ist frische waren elektrische wandel
das constance durch zuordnen aber es war
ein milchlaster nicht so noch nie
gegessen habe
der ist aber weg dementsprechend war
wirklich gut also an den milchpreis von
meiner mama kommt keiner dran an den
arzt von meiner oma natürlich auch nicht
dementsprechend muss ich da so ein paar
pünktchen abzieht aber kurz danach kommt
die kreisstadt
denk mal den heutigen tag mit einer
stabil ich bin direkt hinter mama und
oma oder man erst mal schauen wie ich
glaube nämlich von meiner oma findet
nämlich auch nicht zusammenkommt wir
sehen uns zum mittagessen wieder
willkommen zum mittagessen ich habe hier
1,2 kilogramm kartoffeln hier hinten ist
schon wasser auf dem herd ich muss mich
nämlich bei der für das klar ich mache
heute mittag 30 appetit und das ist für
mich ein großer mut weil das ist eins
meiner lieblingsessen von meiner mama ja
aber wenn dann nur mit kartoffeln spinat
kam es an käse muss auch gleich wenn die
kartoffeln passen sind schnell von
bremen und spinat tauchen zwei kilogramm
gefrorenen spinat kartoffeln müssen
gleich noch enthalten deshalb ist es auf
jeden fall ganz wichtig dass das der
erste arbeitsschritt ist er machen soll
heute unsere kartoffeln 1,2 kilo kommen
jetzt in den park so und jetzt hier
kochen wie ich schnell zum supermarkt
zwei kilometer an habe ich nie sein soll
ich meine spieler halbzeit gespielt wird
wenn man das ein bisschen besser
koordinieren haben würde dann wäre der
jetzt bereits aufgebaut über nacht oder
wie auch immer ich muss jetzt mit
probieren das mit der mikrowelle oder so
so die kartoffeln sollten jetzt auch
fertig sein
es sieht gut aus ich schütte sie also
ich muss irgendwie diesen spinat
auftauen
du wirst diesmal auf dem backblech ich
habe mir für meine kitchen ist so ein
fleischwolf mit dem werde ich jetzt
probieren die kartoffeln fein zu machen
entsteht diese kartoffel preschen mit
der macht meine mama das aber ich mache
es jetzt hier mit
es gebe zwar einen sehr schlauen wenn
wir jetzt perfekte gepressten kartoffeln
gesehen nicht der vermieter endlich das
passieren soll ich wirklich kurz vor
schluss und wusste was die webseite
nicht komplett freie hand gegeben keine
noten sagt das ist gerne fleisch los
sein soll
die verdoppelt irgendwie richtig schnell
noch zum auskühlen bringen sondern die
vom balkon wie er jetzt den islam für
spieler nehmen cuisine ausbringen alt
wir wollen die gesamte flüssigkeit die
wir raus bekommen können herausbekommen
das ganze mal breiter das für uns ja mal
richtig um ein golf sowie man nicht wie
das ist wenn er sagt sehr teuer in
berlin mitte verkaufen könnte sich an
leiter in diese schüssel mit gehacktem
spinat kommen jetzt von meiner mama vier
esslöffel seine größe und 4
außerdem vier esslöffel graden apanage
und übrigens leute bin mal so frei
wieder mal ein bisschen was dann falls
ihr gerne die rezepte nachkochen wie ich
hier so mache dann in köln ist dabei was
geben auch dass wir sehr gespannt ist
ein fan des propheten gemeint das hören
wir jetzt mal ein bisschen unter haben
warum jetzt 4
die trend geben die eigens dazu und 4
haben jetzt zu schnell geschlagen
gelbe passiert auch noch reinarbeiten
eischnee unterziehen und brauche ich
noch ein bisschen petersilie einen halb
esslöffel so die kartoffeln sind jetzt
auch erkaltet das heißt wir geben jetzt
meint ihr dazu
das muss jetzt alles unternehmen der
stadt aber noch nichts und 6
daraus vor mich jetzt so circa
tischtennisballgroße kügelchen let's go
ein gesamtes tablett voll es ist immer
noch was da also wie gesagt es war echt
ein bisschen übertrieben wie viel ich
macht habe aber die kommen jetzt in das
kochende wasser und wir fangen jetzt
einfach mal an hier die ersten rang oder
projektierer einzugeben jetzt kommt der
moment der wahrheit wenn sie
auseinanderfallen dann habe ich einfach
nur verpackt sollte ihr seht hier sind
verfallen warum hat das mädel paket das
bis vier mal fünf dazu arbeite jetzt das
mehl 1 was ich vergessen hatte
ach scheiße aber nicht verrückt ist nein
das ist aber natürlich treten junge
leute zweiter versuch was hat es getan
kochen sie bleiben zusammen mein gott
wenn dies angela partie hoch schwimmen
sagen will so fertig wie wir drüben
inzwischen schon mal in die bütt und sei
bei dem sie rüber sind die sei bei
butter und sie dann da noch ein bisschen
drin geschmack aufnehmen
also dann live mein lieber das war eine
reise auf dem weg zu diesem schrank oder
präziser den spinat kartoffelklößen
haben die zuschauer gesehen
seine hände gerade noch aus sagt wir
haben alles gesehen yamaha ich dachte du
bist krank oder sogar schon echt komisch
also dann wichtig hielt parmesan hat uns
genau richtig ich liebe das
du machst das ganz genau richtig wir
probieren jetzt wieder wie heute morgen
schon die erste gabe und da bin ich
wirklich besonders gespannt wird das zum
ersten mal gemacht
ja genau zum ersten mal unter anleitung
von meiner mama muss man fairerweise
dazusagen dass die schmecken
da will ich dahin wir sehen uns gleich
auch gegessen ist zu bewerten wie damit
so gut die sind super du hast auch
gegessen der teller ich würde diesmal
ist ein nichts mehr braucht picobello
wie alexander wang oder ps wagen sprang
oder warum 3 im trentino sind da ja dass
priester die irgendwelche gesetze
beschlossen und die heißen so drang
reist also wie strangulieren erwürgen
und recht die sinti brief dass priester
bürger weil dieser von sich jedenfalls
der legende nach modell gerne nach der
legende die gelegenheit gesagt okay aber
egal was die priester damals gemacht
haben
du hast das heute versucht nachzumachen
mit anleitung von deiner mama grüßt hier
raus an max kramer und ja ich hab das
ganze jetzt gegessen und komme mal zum
resultat also hier ist kein fleisch
verwendet worden
nein kein fleisch ich muss sagen mit
käse habe ich es über befreit sieht man
doch meinen ja man ist also da hast du
dann noch zu untersuchen
das ist quasi sein bruder seiner mutter
und hinterher noch mal ein bisschen nach
gesetzen also unterm strich habe ich
noch nie gegessen
hierbei sehr geil habe ich
schon gesagt 2021 muss man mehr davon
essen und weniger von den anderen kam
das ist echt gut also ich muß man diesen
gesundheitsfaktor man braucht schon
normale gerichte hätte ich das jetzt bei
der 7 eingestuft aber weitgehend gesund
ist es für dieses jahr für mich ein ort
wo leute und es ist für mich nicht und
das kann sich hören dass man hat sich
der ganze stress wenigstens gelohnt sich
den contact spd schweißen wir uns wieder
sich auch video ausgedrückt daran denn
wir anknüpfen beim abendessen wir sehen
uns gleich es gibt eine frische pasta
hatten wirklich schon häufig hier aber
das passt dann kann wirklich jeden
abrunden ich werde eine machen die wir
bisher noch nicht hatten nichts weiter
als charity knoblauch basilikum und ein
bisschen paar sachen praktischer wieder
reach 500 gramm mehl eier wie essen und
ich komme gleich im büro weil wir seit
einiger zeit im büro mit dave und das
ist auch mit grund dafür dass ich so
viel hochladen und das ist so spaß daran
wieder gefunden hat youtube videos zu
machen
da wären die gleich essen bei lieber
sollte ja kommt dass uns doch einfach
mal bei dem büro essen dann reicht auch
mal dort absolut gute idee ich bereite
nur auch entspannt jetzt schon weil die
pasta teigboden nur der text fertig
haben ein bisschen öl dran gemacht hat
er sehr trocken war
so sieht doch super aus dem päckchen
frischhaltefolie und verdeutlichen auch
nie den gleichen poliert eine firma die
gleiche jacke die liga hatte auch den
ganzen tag an hatte ich jetzt mal ein
bisschen mehr aus wenigstens ist unser
gesamtes büro videoüberwacht und kommt
auch andere sehen als nur überwachung
film stimmt dass andere perspektive
wir füllen wasser ein
also wenn leute ihr keplers wir formen
daraus so ein häuschen gehen auch die
größere stufe und dann ziehen wir es
durch die erste mal so ich mache müsse
weiter mit der pasta aber jetzt im
schnelldurchlauf wir sehen uns auch in
die welt fährt
[Musik]
wir machen weiter dem 13 knoblauchzehen
schnappen einlassen wir ins waschbecken
fallen und sie in retz platten ja auch
ins waschbecken bald nicht um unten
abschneiden der zwischenzeit dass ich
schon mal eine ordentliche menge
olivenöl warm werden
sie fragt wie viel es ist eine
ordentliche menge ich habe leider pech
gehabt und hier ein paar knoblauchzehen
erwischt die die nicht große triebe
haben schon die muss sich also schnell
entfernt da habe ich auch vier genommen
statt rein und die schneiden wir dann in
feine scheiben wenn der knoblauch
geschnitten ist dann geben wir ihnen
auch schon direkt in das weiße olivenöl
sind auch sehen kann ist der herd
absolut ebenso das ganze öl sammelt sich
hier sofort da ist ein platz frei jetzt
geht es auch schon weiter wir schnappen
uns hier unsere ganzen tomaten die haben
wie gesagt ein bisschen öl abbekommt wir
nutzen dafür cherrytomaten aus dem
einfachen grund dass harry thomas länger
reifen das heißt große tomaten die man
im supermarkt gerade im winter werden
grün gepflückt und reifen dann erst wenn
sie unterwegs sind soll die gehen jetzt
hinein wie lassen wir jetzt einfach
kochen wir rühren aber ein bisschen in
der pfanne herum weil wir wollen
natürlich nicht dass der knoblauch
anbrennt ansonsten ist das jetzt schon
quasi fast unser ganzes rezept die haut
platz vier zu langsam auf und das ist
sehr sehr gut weil jetzt gleich geben
die zum agieren sagt ab es wird sehr
krimi und 70 gegeben jetzt die
auch in den kopf hinein immer gut salzen
frische nudeln
man kann die kirschtomaten dann flach
drücken eine frischere tomatensoße als
die gibt es nicht ist einfach so also
ich hab mir grad übrigens in den finger
geschnitten ich weiß gar nicht wie ich
habe es einfach nicht mal bemerkt wir
sehen jetzt auch schon das verwandelt
sich tatsächlich jetzt hier in eine
schöne tomaten koste also auch so
zwischen den jetzt wissen wir auch schon
in die masse konsistenz fühlt sich sehr
gut an zuschüssen ab jetzt haben wir
wirklich auch alle bedingungen an eine
frische italienische pasta erfüllt
basilikum tomaten und würden das ganze
noch mal schnell ein der basilikum
braucht er ja nicht lange drin oder raus
punkten unsere frische nudeln drüber und
jetzt kann man das ja schon durch menge
frischer haben wir da oben drüber gold
gehört
[Musik]
eine frische pasta für dich dass du dir
gerne schmecken und kennen sie sprachen
in ersten niedrigen seitenblicke okay
gut ja gucken muss ich fertig war
wir sehen uns gleich und aufgegessen ist
sowie werden also ich weiß nicht was das
war es war er gegen das süßliche
man kennt sie die cocktailtomaten
aufgegessen ich fand das ganze gut für
pasta muss ich sagen es hat mich jetzt
nicht umgehauen
okay so manchmal hast du das ja würde
ist irgendwas neues und das ist so
damit wir auch das rating gegen diese
auswirken weil die gerichte vorher war
wirklich gut gestartet so gebe ich hier
für eine 5 wobei das einfach eine 5 ist
ich könnte das auch einmal die woche ist
so ich bin ja eher doch nicht so an ich
versteh ich habe das sehr gerne gegessen
und ich muss auch jemand übergeben für
den gesamten tag wie das ganze format
also dass du überhaupt wieso was
ausgedacht hat für den zuschauer nicht
sehr geil
auch das jetzt wieder so aktiv ist nicht
sehr geil freunde hier gibt es eine
statistik zeitungen lieber hier
einwenden wenn man die gesamt wert in
der statistik wie viele von den hier
schwingen da draußen die videos gucken
aber das sind so viele bei mir das nie
ich glaube dass ja das wird mal 70
prozent das mal gesagt habe er sich von
euch gucken adidas habe ich einfach
nicht mehr die zeit stimmt nicht ganz
eigenartige sind aber wir wissen was zu
tun ist wohl dass kurz nach unterstützen
maximal sagen hier 2021 durchstarter
ganz genau hier sehen wir mal die
gesamtwertung eingeblendet und wir sehen
uns nächsten sonntag
hierzu
[Musik]